well I'm joined Now by Anne Robinson who
is about as uncensored as a human being
could possibly be so thank you you're on
the you're on the right show I'm going
to be the ginger to your Fred Astor I
love that I love that just briefly give
me your what's your verdict about Boris
Johnson what do you make of it I'm
astonished anyone is surprised he's been
lying since about 1987 when he was first
fired off the times so we know he's
narcissistic he doesn't tell the truth
and all he does is think about himself
and and that's what he did in the speech
why do you think he's finally met his
maker in terms of everyone finally well
I don't think it could go on I mean I I
don't think he could go on what's
interesting is that I think he's gone
away totally puzzled why they should get
rid of him because he's deluded about
what he's like yeah it's how important
is I mean this is a character debate
really more than policy I think because
you could construct an argument on
policy Ukraine to covet vaccines to you
know brexit if you agree with it that on
policy he's done some quite good stuff
um but on character all the things that
made him popular have now become sticks
to beat him with how important is
character with it's really prime
minister I I think I think he was
probably well I don't think I know he
was the Prime Minister he was the leader
of the Tory party to win 80 seats yes
then he should have gone yeah I think
you're right I mean he did the hard bit
I mean but they never would have got 80
seats without him have you met him Boris
yeah quite a few times what do you make
of him I think he's exactly what you see
you know Ruffles his hair goes
I mean that's it I'm I I think after he
said something he's convinced he's told
the truth yeah and he's got away with
the point is it's rather like Maxwell
and everyone said afterwards oh we knew
he was like that he we knew yeah but
when you think he was fired from the
times fired by Michael Howard over fired
by my ex-husband all the time Charlie
Wilson yes yeah
um fired by Michael Howard goes to The
Spectator promises Conrad black that he
won't take a seat he does take a seat
but Conrad black says yeah but he's put
the circulation up and he's good
publicity so everyone sort of gives in
because he's a good actor he did do well
as London mayor I mean indisputably and
he got any one he won twice as London
there he is an electoral winner until
this moment do you think the calculation
became that actually he'd gone from
being an election winner to potentially
an election Loser on a I think I think
my auntie Betty and Birkdale which is a
very good Benchmark I think she's she's
now fooled by what he's doing
um but nevertheless if if you look after
one non-entity after another the Tory
MPS we don't know who they are people
don't know who's in the cabinet
um he's he's the only one who could say
go on the Liverpool Empire on a Friday
night and you'll get an audience yeah
and he's he does this stick where he
turns up to do public speaking where
he's being paid before he's prime
minister and he would be the buffoon and
he'd forget punch lines and all this
kind of thing and you would think it was
all just bumbling Bros in fact he used
to do that every time yeah same joke the
same the whole thing was pretty
manufactured but it was hugely engaging
and popular I've seen him be in rooms
where people they're drawn to it like a
magnet but also I heard you discussing
whether he'll keep his seat yeah can I
explain a split second to you yeah
because that will be when he goes and
starts making a lot of money uh on the
international speaking Yeah he will make
a huge Fortune out of his book yeah
he'll go out with a bang and he'll start
with a bang somewhere else yeah we
haven't heard the last of Boris Johnson
absolutely I mean in a way he's like our
Trump isn't he he's like Donald Trump
yeah he's a big sort of buffooned sort
of Style TV superstar that people either
love or hate but he's got an appeal to
large numbers of people and he's got an
ability I would think going out of this
to make a lot of money and also he talks
human I mean I heard one MP earlier
talking about leveling up he is out
there in the country no one has the
foggiest idea of what leveling up means
and they think brexit's gone
um I think it'll be really interesting
whether the vote is in two weeks or this
or goes through the summer because it's
time for people to trip over yes I
totally agree what do you make of carry
in all this is probably had enough her
body language today I mean they've
released pictures of of Boris being
comforted by Carrie and their son wolf
and the little one she was obviously
carrying earlier outside she looked like
a woman to me who could not wait to get
out of there I think I mean being a
young man bringing up two kids in Danish
with all this hellish stuff going on
yeah a tiny flap yeah in Darling Street
yeah uh no help in the house
did they bring some of it on themselves
for example there's a big story I think
it's a big story
um breaking tonight in terms of the
details is Simon Walters top political
journalist in the independent they've
got hold of the linked invoice from
wallpaper gate which is one of the
sticks used to beat the the Johnsons uh
200 000 pound invoice and what's amazing
is the detail that Simon Waters has
Unearthed here in this invoice which
included a
3675 pound drinks trolley said to have
been like the one owned by ballet dancer
Rudolf nuriev and 2 260 pounds worth of
gold wallpaper the one that we'd heard
rumors about two sofas costing more than
fifteen thousand pounds and so on and so
on lots of pretty lurid extravagant
would be really interesting is Mrs prime
minister coming in and saying I hate
that wallpaper yes they're all allowed
to change him the question is you know
when the Browns came in for example they
deliberately didn't spend lots of money
doing up there
because I understand his taxpayer money
yeah
Carrie what happens to her after this
and once you become a first lady and you
have all the trappings and everything
should be rich but is there anything
quite like the power that goes with
these jobs I think if you've had the
experience she's had in the last year I
think having to wear the hats yeah the
hats are very difficult well actually
all the attention on how you look all
the time it must be it must be
unbearable pressure for a young woman
yeah to have everything that you wear
and everything you say get scrutinized
when you're not even the person in the
position of power I think you know she
she is much criticized in a way for
example that Dennis Thatcher was never
criticized Yes actually and I suppose
really all of them have a lot of power
yeah I don't suppose she's she's had any
more power than such a Mr satra had when
you look at the runners and writers for
taking over fantastic and it's wide open
can I say that the only person I thing
out in the country anyone's heard of two
one is Rishi and the other is
um the health secretary was down kissing
what's he called Matt Hancock yeah you
see they'd know Matt Hancock penny more
than what's her job I don't think people
would recognize that you know what's her
job yeah is she even in the cabin at the
moment yeah she is but what was her last
job I actually can't even remember no
you can't remember right yeah she was
actually yeah but can you imagine going
out and asking anyone uh who Tom
tugenhart is they have no idea well I
know I mean on their side yeah I mean I
know he's being simply because I'm a
political animal but I mean with the one
name you haven't come up with is who's
at 250 to one at the moment to be prime
minister do you know who that is no go
on me
250 to one rose I think it should really
between you and Charlie Marlin because
he knows how to plumb exactly which at
least the kind of heartbeat of this
country actually yeah and I think it's
interesting that he fell out of love
with Boris he wasn't Boris fan and for a
lot of them he likes Angie Javid who's
got an amazing backstage I quite like
Savage actually
um I think that but I do think although
they're writing off
um Rishi yeah I wouldn't write Richie
off it also depends can I just say that
because you're talking an awful lot
um you're not going to smile
okay I take my bollock he's like a man
yeah okay it really makes a difference
with 1922 committees stick with the rule
of it going out to the country yeah yeah
and I agree uh and fantastic that's it
I'm afraid we've got a busy night it's
historic a night of history but you've
been a major part of it good looking as
ever you are thank you very much Anne
come back
anytime uh lovely to see you thank you
very much